és én úgy gondolom hogy ez ez fogja
elhozni az új aranykort ez fogja elhozni
azt hogy sokkal kevesebbet fogunk
dolgozni ahogy például az autógyártás
elterjedése hozta el azt hogy hogy nem
hat nap 12 órát per nap kellett
dolgozzanak az emberek hanem németország
déli részén először ugye
badenwürtenberg államterületén a mondjuk
a mercedes gyárban bevezették a 8-9 órás
műszakot és a a heti öt napos
munkaprogramot ami aztán elterjedt
mindenhol pont azért mert az
autógyártásnak volt egy óriási
hozzáadott értéke és leghamarabb
szerintem a négy naapos
munkahét elterjedését azt azt szerintem
mindenként a a a mesterséges
intelligencia
terjedésének köszönhetjük majd